[Applause]
if you want to watch
I can't really do another True Crime
what about oh my God she even has your
hair
[Music]
the first question any platform is gonna
ask is what's the hook
first step is
that was nice
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Salma Hayek Bingo
how's the coffee dog [__] I did not say
that like that this is an adaptation of
Joan's life can everybody that has
screenberry watch this hey how you doing
out there cool [__]
this guy had been
so that's what your documentary is about
the details are so awful it is
irresistible
I love it
[Music]
lost
and we both feel that you could use a
break
think I'd like that very much
he got kicked off the movie said weeks
ago Nick's offering 30k for the first
photo ever
these [__] would kill themselves if
we didn't take their picture
[Music]
the pharmacy writing down your number I
won't mind
I'm a crazy person you're a little crazy
it'd be all crazy one
all right
it's taking you off
you must be humble in the face of it
the things they can do
[Music]
you not seen Joan is awful
I hope it's on my list